all right
really where have you been this year I
know that this is a thing yes but he
does that a lot yes okay
let him try yeah
I beginning to think now he just does it
so that I can be seen as a babysitter
yes just making wild noises putting my
hands over his yeah I put my hand over
his mouth in all sorts are there new
characters in this movie
no I didn't know that yeah it's
interesting because he you know it would
we were paid up a lot during The
Avengers so it's literally oh my gosh
right of course you were diving on
grenades left front and center it's kind
of fun it brightens up today it makes me
look like a saint or at least
besseristic than he is and I'm not sure
I am or would be on my own but with him
doing it intentionally no no no no I
don't I think possibly he's like right
come on Match let's see how quick he was
and I'm joking of course he's not there
I don't think so anyway